[Music]
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now
lutheran's conservatory of the fine arts
they want to invite you to go exploring
with coraline this weekend we're going
to talk about the show that opened last
night we have the dean of fine arts dr
emily slater hi dr slater how are you i
am mostly sunny how are you good all
right we also have logan tomlinson she's
playing mrs forcible yes in the show
coraline so you guys opened last night i
hope everything is going great
absolutely um so tell us about the show
if someone is not familiar with the show
coraline what are you guys doing well
the show is about a young girl who
realizes that she's not the center of
the universe when she finds another
world outside her own so it's a really
important lesson that she learns and she
meets these great people along the way
and ends up saving the day
but apparently uh from what i understand
your character gets stuck on the in this
alternate world or whatever you want to
call it she certainly does she's
actually part of the alternate world yes
i am so my character is super extra
she just goes out there with everything
and shows everything
i'm extra in the real world and also in
the other world where i perform my
monologue yeah so i i from what i
understand coraline has issues with her
real family and then they try to get
resolved in the
other side absolutely she thinks that
nobody loves her appreciates her
understands her so she goes into a world
where everybody does but that's not
everything that she hoped it would be
so your character mrs forcible yes
tell us about your monologue what are we
going to hear do you just want to go
into a little bit of it yes i will love
to go into some of it all right so she's
in character she's got this skull here
yes i do okay
to be or not to be that is the question
coraline whether it is nobler of the
mind to suffer the strength and arrows
of outrageous fortune or to take arms
against the sea of troubles and by
opposing them and them to die to sleep
to die to sleep to sleep perhaps to
dream
ah
wow that's pretty strong
so uh how many more performances do you
have to go and how do we get to go see
you guys well there's a performance
tonight and then there's two on saturday
and one on sunday there's a sunday
matinee please join us on our website at
bigconservatory.com
and you can get your tickets there how
many students are in the cast and is it
a big deal it's a big deal to get cast
in a show like this because it's a very
small cast okay so yes how many kids in
the cast i think 12 is that correct um
something like that like 12 and then we
also have a tech crew of students as
well so it's a large group of students
and you guys have been putting on
productions there for quite a while 22
years yeah and this is just the latest
in a long series of great performances
absolutely we've got more on the dock as
well so you can see all of that
information on our website and we'd love
to have you come join us for all of our
shows awesome well dr slater it's a
pleasure to meet you and thanks for
doing that great work from the cultural
arts for our students in southern nevada
logan good luck to you that was awesome
i love the skull i love the outfit and i
can't wait to come see the show thank
you
and uh chrissy our producer who was
working with that interview i wanted to
make sure wanted to know if
logan did her own makeup because it was
really fantastic and she did really yeah
wow
multi-talented who did the makeup on the
skull though i think that was a melted
candle
well stage makeup is always so
exaggerated because you have to see it
from way back you know in the audience
so when you see it up close it's like
wow that's pretty neat though and the
talent of high school students
really cool go check it out over faith
lutheran yeah good stuff